tech gambino thank you for the tier one
resub 67 months in a row 67 total
all right
round two
of the hour hourly rapid arena
all right how do i want to reply to that
one
i'll go with c6
first time playing this guy
chilly
i have that right
yep
okay d5
how's white going to react a chop all
right so this is likely turning into
slav land exchange no all right bishop
there
i don't think the
the decision to
fianchetto
is the greatest
well although
it no no no it remains to be seen
um all right why do i think this
this guy if he ends up going here
uh i don't think the bishop on g2 will
be so productive but if white chooses a
setup with d3 which is supporting e4
which will strike at my
best pawn
that's a little different
i don't believe i want to
make a decision yet with my light square
bishop
i'm pretty sure this guy knows where he
belongs so let's get him there for
starters
this is the more flexible piece of my
two queen side miners
and
now now there's a little less pressure
here something i need to keep in
mind is
as soon as i move this bishop queen here
can surface
another thing i should note is that
maybe white's decision to not
uh establish a pawn in the center
i'm i'm looking more at d4
all of a sudden
i think d4 is a good decision
uh yeah i'm definitely looking at this
d4 move
the knight can't go to e4 now
in reply
they don't have that direct sight of e4
so d4 with what is my follow-up d3
that punches a huge hole in the light
squares
and makes life difficult for this guy
i'm gonna go for this
i think i'm
i think maybe i could have
considered yeah no no no i don't know
right now because of that again
but at this point right here i believe
d4 is best
because now this is very clumsy
stability of the clean knight clearly in
question no checks
against my king
knight here
that's short-lived
i have this
defended twice
um
a six
wait knight knight b4
knight b4
yeah okay i mean knight b4 still i could
play d3 i don't
i don't necessarily even have to react
to the knight on b4 i could maybe say
to myself you know what you're not
bothering me
i have that c6 square c7 square covered
something i do have to be mindful of
though is if i do play a6
maybe queen a4 is the reply
queen a4
stops this because of the unprotected
rook and adds a third attacker to d4
so
maybe best is to first
play d3
um i have to be i have to be careful um
i feel like i'm in the better position
here
the thing i want to keep in mind though
is that white is one move away from
castling and i still have
three tempi
to make before i'm castled so that's a
little concerning that difference there
uh
can uh
can be a problem if things start to
become a little too complicated and
opened in the center but
this d3 move is putting a
is making life
very difficult for white to complete
queen side development
but if this exchange
happens this this is going to be an
isolated pawn if they capture
um
i should be pointing out i guess that i
i can't
i can't recapture
because of the fork
but i'm i'm okay with that
this is this is a good move still i'm
pretty sure
because of uh
you know double isolated pawns that
that wouldn't be so so great for white
okay
so this is this is a little different
now if i play a6 and
queen here
a6 queen here
i can follow
with
maybe bishop to d7
trying to figure out what is best
i'll go with a6
let's let's see what uh this the
decision will be
okay knight back
okie dokie
e5 or not
i don't i don't see why i shouldn't
play e5
let's let's go with it then
i can go too
safely
all right that's a that's a there's a
gap here
my first thought is if i could
maintain a piece on that square
this whole queen side is dead
i somehow have
pawn on b3
those two pawns two points negate eight
all right i could go with another push
but i think i'm asking for trouble
knight there it's hit three times let's
look at something else
king side development
um
i don't really want to stop b5 i don't
think
hmm
where's my dark square bishop belong
not really sure
where i want to go
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna baby step
it i guess
i guess here
yepper
all right we'll put the bishop here
yeah they're they're cruising man
they're going quick
let's put this rook here
want to get off of this diagonal all
right yeah they're really flying
that is for sure
i want to get this one in
defend here offset the knight
i have to pick up the pace here
castle let's castle
i could uh i could be playing b5
play f6
f6 is a good controlling
i move i may want to play b5
their queen has a tough time moving
let's let's force something here let's
go with b5
i was thinking at
this kind of stuff but
you know just to slip the bishop in
there but i have to take some care over
this pawn i think maybe
knight there and rook here
i'm no longer seeing this point directly
and if knight here what's my plan
it's to
just take it
with my
knight
and then address the thread on e5
um he has to he okay so that's those are
the two
those are the two options but now now i
have oh that's another point of b5 i
have bishop c4
all right maybe
maybe i could carry on with
going two squares
one or two
i'm gonna go two
i'm gonna go two to control e4 is to
control these three pieces
because if this knight can't move these
two pieces don't see the world
and i'm in a spot to play e4 yes i
should have pulled the trigger much
faster i feel
on that uh on that move all right
be careful here maybe i bring my knight
back to its favorite square
to be careful of the pressure here
huh oh
all right i can't have it all can i okay
i'm gonna go with
yeah but then there's f3
oh okay i have this move that's right
almost forgot about that one
so the if if i had played knight to f6
there's tricks here
unleashing two two attackers here so
bishop
this move solves both problems
the the threats on
d3 directly and interferes with the
coordination on c6
i'm just realizing there's a bishop
check or a knight jump into here yeah
okay
and not really
a whole lot i could do about that i
should probably challenge that guy as
soon as possible
so here i'm doing that my queen is
defending here
you know there's this kind of stuff but
capturing on either square i get to
recapture and be defending this so
there's no longer an idea to swipe the
knight and then win the e5 pawn
currently i think that this guy here's
my best piece
um i'm threatening this guy three times
so
something's got to give him immediately
challenging the piece that landed in my
house
two minutes back on the clock
my knights still stand well
okay
so no minor piece imbalances
i would love to see f4
boom
huge
pawn chain
these two pieces are negated but i could
probably go right in for this
i don't want i don't think i even want
to the knight back f3 i don't want the
file to open up
oh no i'm still doing it
taking with the queen i have this under
control
their knight is almost dead
the knight really is dead
has these two squares but i have uh
it only has these two squares ever for
the remainder of the game
but a pawn on g5 and a pawn on e4 will
constantly give the knight problems
so this guy's dead this is their only
active plan i can't really stop f3 if i
had two moves in a row i'd play g4
g5 g4
but uh here's something else they maybe
have to worry about
this move
let's start with this one
so if f3 now the queen is squashed
that one hurts
this was something i wanted to get in
much earlier this kind of long-winded
thing i was pointing out but
at the time it didn't really feel right
so they have to throw something
in the line of fire they're in a pin
and i'll probably end up keeping them in
a pin
i may have to be careful
no actually i i could take straight away
because they're still in a they're still
in a pin
let's see what they come up with they
may resign
so this is this is really dating back to
that earliest moment
i'll take
connected passer and i'll look to get
the knight into d3
plenty of ways to do it from here
i may be perfectly content with giving
up my e4 pawn at this stage instead of
trying to babysit it
so i want my i want my knight right here
uh let me see first
yeah let's let's begin with let's begin
with this move
so it's the plan chop i'm gonna take
with the bishop and be on the rook and
then get my bishop into this
super square on d3 where it defends
everything
i could also go for this now my queen's
defending this pawn
in this
along the rank
now
the knight would be obstructing
the queen's vision of e4 if it was on e6
to guard it from c4 though
and now this guy's going in so i don't
know if i completed my thought earlier
this this is really dating all the way
back to d4
the d4 d3 push
this had a tremendous
influence on the quality of white's
pieces
so we'll see i don't know what to really
recommend here for what
night here can't really be stopped
no checks against my king
i'm up a full night
big passer
remove the block hater
push through
see
not a time ticker
is that what we're seeing a time ticker
all right we're gonna find out
there we go all right so
i could take on poisson
but i really want this square here i
don't care that this guy is passed
all right let's chop and let's go here
i'd love to have connected passes we got
it
full rook now
all right they resigned
you